hello how Rejects Greg here Lego Batman
movie official trailer for I saw like
the first trailer I haven't seen the
other ones so I was like you know what
people are asking that I watch this what
I have a good time
will learn it alone
love annoy keeps the matter master Bruce
your greatest fear is snakes Nelson it's
being a part of a family again
Oh snake Klaus because you put that idea
by Eddie sir you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
or don't we I thought I was being
sarcastic
answer just a little reggae man I can
only look you in the eyes right now
Superman is my greatest enemy bad guy
that say that I don't currently have a
bad guy I am fighting a few different
place I like to fight around hi Barbara
Gordon new police commissioner it's my
dream the police force to team up with
Batman what would that be better I hate
everything you just said
Wow that's Riku cuz last check I only
had one but well luckily for us you left
your costume beckon oh no
under your clothes that's perfect
that's gonna be a funny ass film that's
gonna be really exciting I think this is
just such a great marketing transitional
move because Batman was the highlight of
the lego movie he's like usually the
character everyone walks away talking
about not because he's like accurately
portraying Batman boo because he's he's
Batman but with a totally different kind
of personality I love the other
exploring this like cocky side how his
like base human emotion is this guy who
has a fear of like connection a fear of
owner ability and cuz that is Batman you
know I've always sort of felt that if
Batsy seriously
whoa helicopter car alarm this place is
[ __ ] noisy I live in Van Nuys amend a
lot of people who've actually watched
this channel who live in Van Nuys I'm
hoping to move out of Van Nuys soon
because [ __ ] like that now I probably
still didn't hear that alarm you or not
but anyway when I grew up loving Batman
that was really from the Batman animated
series so it's cool to kind of see like
a cartoon comedy of Batman and I know
that the Lego Batman games did pretty
well actually
and I even played a little bit of them
on Nintendo Wii for a little while you
got some really cool animation here it
looks like there's an actual like story
to explore I feel like this is like a
treat for kids family Batman fans like
this looks like a movie that's really
targeted for children but it still looks
like a really cool film just like how I
felt about the lego movie like this
targeted for kids but this is like an
awesome move really imaginative really
inventive I'm excited to see how much
they really explored Gotham City like I
feel like we're probably gonna get more
out
comics that we would want to have a
scene and even some of the Nolan films
or something like I feel like we're
gonna get a lot more of comic mayhem a
lot more tribute to the actual source
material but done in like a satire
comedic way cuz instead of just making
like Batman jokes I feel like they took
time to actually make these guys
characters and let the humor and the
jokes come out from the characters that
they sort of re-envision them as I
thought this could be it actually like
just a really good time a really good
film I I'm excited to see a little bit
of like Bruce Wayne's super III like I
like this is Bruce Wayne interpretation
to actually make sense in a lot of ways
if he just examined Bruce Wayne as like
a human being from a psychological
perspective like this guy does this mask
so much emotionally that it would make
sense that he developed this really
closed-off cocky persona to make up for
a lot of the emotional damage that's in
this guy I want to see his relationship
with Robin I feel like the writers of
this film probably took the time to just
ask themselves like how would these
people sort of be in real life and then
added comedy to it I think it's gonna be
a really well-done film and the
animation looks great I love Batman and
I like that they're doing more than just
Batman like you're getting a lot of the
bat world in here so [ __ ] yeah I'm
excited for this film
alright Rejects ever knew the channel
subscribe to do it and get accepted and
shout out to mel gibson i've been
declaring for a long long time that you
deserve a comeback and I did videos this
year before blood father even came out
saying that I want you to have your
comeback this year your hacksaw Ridge
everyone loves your [ __ ] movie so I
thought this would be an appropriate
video makes sense Lego Batman hacksaw
bridge why not give you a shout out here
you're welcome now I know you could use